all the videos that i've made so far for
cyberpunk have been lore videos from
story to character analysis to side
quest to sections we've covered a lot of
important things from the game but today
i want to take a step back take a more
laid back approach this video if you
will spoiler warning ahead as i want to
discuss the endings of cyberpunk and the
possible future dlcs specifically what
ending is canon and what the future dlcs
may have in store for us and what they
could possibly be this would be the
biggest opportunity for you to get
involved so i encourage you to comment
your thoughts on this topic so we can
have a large discussion of differing
opinions
the choice of a canon ending in dlc is
based on the assumption that the dlc for
the game will be
taking place after the ending as a way
to officially resolve the story with no
cliffhangers
so i'll be forming my opinion with that
assumption in mind as if it was just a
random dlc you could do in the middle of
any playthrough the ending wouldn't
matter too much and there'd be tons of
things the dlc could be about then we
would just be making huge guesses at
that point but if it's related to the
endings we can at least narrow down some
sort of plot for the dlc regardless to
start i want to explain why i think a
dlc will be after the game from the over
3000 comments on my story explained
video i noticed lots of people were
either unhappy with the endings in
general or felt empty with there being
no resolution i understand not
everything needs to have an ending and
having an open ending for a story allows
for a lot of cool theories like this
video but i know that cd projekt red
could definitely benefit from closing
this story this isn't the first time
something like this has happened in a
video game games like mass effect 3 and
final fantasy 15 have changed things in
their story at the player's request but
i think a better example would be
fallout 3.
you don't need to understand the ending
of fall through to get this idea as i'll
explain it in the most basic
terms possible but basically at the end
of the game someone has to activate this
thing called a purifier but the problem
is that once a person enters they can't
come back out as the radiation will kill
them before they even have a chance to
leave so someone has to sacrifice
themselves the game
originally provided you with two options
you or a person called sentinel lions no
matter the choice the game ends at a
cliffhanger with no way to see what
happens after we are told to revert to
last save players then discovered a
third option however
three companions in the game exist fox a
super mutant sergeant rl3 a robot and
charon a ghoul who are immune to
radiation so they could just walk in and
come out just fine and nobody needs to
die
except when asked to do this they won't
they believe it's your legacy to
activate it as your dad is the creator
of the purifier the ending dialogue even
shuns the player for choosing any option
other than themselves calling them a
coward the capital wasteland is at stake
and they won't help you save it because
it's your destiny and you're called a
coward for making sure no one dies in
the process
how does that make any sense bethesda
noticed this later when fans were
rightfully annoyed and not only added
the ability to have those companions
activate the purifier but also a dlc
called broken steel which continued
after the game's ending so you can see
the world after your choice
i'll bring this up as a reference to
what cd projekt red can do with
cyberpunk some people seem to dislike
all the endings in the game being
furious they waited this long for
nothing good to happen
but some just want a resolution with no
cliffhangers the difference between
fallout and cyberpunk however is that
the beginning of the end is roughly the
same at the end of the day someone has
to activate this purifier with cyberpunk
the endings all go in different places
johnny leaves the city v leaves with the
nomads v comes back to night city after
beating with arasaka v assaults the
crystal palace
all of the endings are different in
place v in different spots in the game
world i don't see cd projekt red making
a dlc taking all of these
into account and adding more to each
ending as that would just be like four
dlcs in one package it could take years
to make and just wouldn't make sense but
i've come up with two possible dlcs that
take two different approaches
one of them would take this fallout 3
approach the other wouldn't
to make this more digestible let's
showcase the endings on screen arasaka
panam rogue the suicide and the secret
ending but four of them have choices at
the end making it more than just five
choices at the beginning
most of the endings also have similar
ending choices so i'll color code them
to make it easier to understand
the rogue and secret choice for v is the
same minus a few small things like rogue
being alive and the secret ending and
the rogue panam and secret ending choice
with johnny in the body is the exact
same once again minus a few small
details the others are unique to
themselves so they don't need any color
coding i firmly believe that both
choices in the panam ending
johnny taking over our body in the
secret and rogue ending and not signing
the contract in the arasaka ending can
all lead to the same dlc
if the dlc is based around saving v's
life there was a lot of claims thrown
out really quickly so let's slow it down
if we as v do not sign the contract we
get sent back to night city in the panam
ending we either leave town with the
alta caldos or johnny leaves town in our
body if johnny takes over our body
during the rogue mission or the secret
ending you get the point he leaves town
in our body
these can all in some way lead to an
after the ending dlc
just like the life paths did in the
beginning of the game as we know the
first
hour or so is different with the life
paths but no matter what we all end up
in the same car and we all end up
finding sandra in the bathtub they could
do the exact same thing but with three
endings as an example to make this easy
let's just say the cure to help v is in
arizona i say that because panam's
ending when discussing bee's illness she
mentions how there are people in arizona
that might be able to help us so the
goal is to get to arizona if we start
with panams ending the place they are
traveling to during that ending is
arizona so maybe the dlc starts where
they left off on this tank and then you
arrive at the base talk with them all to
call those set up camp then talk with
panama's contacts that'll help v's
illness and the life path and the dlc
will start here
for the arasaka ending it's assumed v is
sent back to night city to live out the
rest of his days he realizes that
arasaka didn't help so he starts looking
for more options of course since you
were up in space for god knows how long
it may be hard to find some contacts the
question is pan am if she had plans to
leave night city with or without you
maybe calling her will let v know of her
location so he can drive out there and
meet her or if she can't be reached
maybe you can travel back to the
original alda caldo camp cause i'm
assuming not all of them left with us so
they can lead you to arizona and then to
panam you discuss your issue she lets
you know about her contacts you call
them just like before and that ends the
life path where the dlc starts
the other option is johnny and this
one's a little different johnny leaves
town now in v's body he's clearly upset
if this is the original plan we hear
throughout the game is that johnny stays
in cyberspace with alt and v goes back
into his body we may not like the
outcome but what's done is done and
johnny wants to live on for him but
maybe after some time he realizes that
he really misses v
or he feels awful because in a
roundabout way he did cause his death
and wants things to go back to before so
he starts looking for answers maybe he
even calls pan
am this one's a little fishy as we can
tell from the voicemail she clearly
hates him but maybe he can reconcile
with her and explain the situation he
then makes it to arizona through some
way and the life path ends
the obvious issue is that johnny is
still in control of the body is there a
possibility of playing this whole thing
as johnny essentially making a totally
different storyline as cool as that
sounds i don't think that would happen
but
is a nice thing to think about if that
doesn't work maybe johnny goes into
cyberspace and has v
take over again i understand there's a
lot of holes in this but i feel like
this can work out somehow
taking into account all the endings and
the things we just discussed that
provides the player with a resolution to
v's illness accessible from
five out of the nine endings in the game
the four endings that wouldn't work
are the suicide ending the signing the
contract with arasaka and the two
endings that send us to the crystal
palace but maybe there's an argument
that you can make those accessible too
regardless more than half the endings
would be considered canon making players
feel like their personal decisions
throughout the story and the ending they
actually chose meant something our next
one however is not going to be as
forgiving with canon endings
this would be a dlc that would be about
ai mind control mr blue eyes and perales
as i've said in both my mr blue eyes
videos and my peralas video i
and many others want a continuation of
this story either making it a full dlc
about it or having it as some sort of
side quest in a future dlc that
continues the story as it's a remarkable
questline with a ton of questions as in
a part of some of the biggest theories
in the game
i highly recommend you watch both of my
videos on these topics to get a better
understanding if you're confused but
from the theories and evidence from the
quest there is major proof that mr
bluewise is up to something sinister and
the crystal palace is next on his list
this dlc assuming it takes place after
an ending would make the path of glory
ending or assaulting the crystal palace
the only viable option mr bluewise only
contacts us because we assaulted arasaka
tower in the other endings we do assault
the tower that being in panama's ending
and rogues ending it in the secret
mission but all of them besides the
obvious path of glory ending all end
with v leaving the city we leave the
city as johnny and v's body or we leave
with the alda caldos the only ending
besides the path of glory ending where
we don't leave the city is technically
not signing the contract at arasaka as
we do
somehow return back to night city but we
didn't assault the tower in that ending
we just walked into arasaka hq got put
up in a spaceship and came back months
later he meets with us during this
ending because not only are we the
legend of the afterlife it's also
because we crippled arasaka and from our
previous video we do make the assumption
that he works for militech a rival
company to arasaka so it makes sense
this is the one time he meets with us
taking all that in this is why it
wouldn't make sense for any of the
endings in this game but this exact one
to work
lots of things point to this being a
major plot point in the game as well but
the biggest reason has to be the
voicemails
after the ending the people we have
helped the people that know us and the
people we have relationships with will
call us at the end of the game all of
them are victor
mama wells judy panam saul mitch rogue
carrie river takamura hanako jeff and
misty
all of them are either main characters
being pennam victor misty takamura and
rogue romanceable characters like kerry
river judy and panam
related to the main characters like mama
wells saul and mitch are only relevant
based on your ending which would be
hanukko who only shows up during the
arasaka ending the only one who doesn't
fit any of these criteria
is jeff there are loads of side
characters in the game that give us
quest to do
rachel lizzie wizzy blue moon nancy
coach fred and the fixers
none of them have left voicemails except
for jeff he has no affiliation to any
group we are with during any of the
endings the being arasaka or the alta
caldos we only do two missions for him
which is less or the same amount of
missions as some of the other side
characters on that list he's not
romanceable he's not related to the main
cast like mama wells misty or victor and
he even deleted our contact info at the
end of the quest line so why is he still
leaving voicemails because this quest
line is important and cd projekt
is making sure that we know that by
having him show up at the end of the
game he's the only outlier on this
entire list so he has to be important
there's literally no other reason for
him to be calling us
other than that that's why i believe
that this quest line will either have
some relevance in a dlc or be the main
plot point for an entire dlc
in the future these are my two theories
for what the future of the game looks
like from a resolution of the endings to
what the dlcs could be
cyberpunk will be getting dlc whether
it's small add-on content or large 15
plus hour stories it'll have something
and i can say with lots of confidence
that one of these two ideas is bound to
happen at some point in the game's life
cycle i think it would be quite
gut-wrenching to never see a resolution
to the ending of the game
never knowing if v will truly live or
die and never see what happens to mr
blue eyes a character who gets at most
five to seven minutes of physical screen
time but is hinted at in quest lines
that can total hours of play time
let me know what you think about this in
the comments down below whether you
agree or disagree i also encourage you
to share with me your theories in the
comments as maybe yours makes more sense
than mine do but as usual like the video
if you enjoyed subscribe for more lore
on cyberpunk and other games in the
future and
take care goodbye
[Music]
bye